[Music]
the first time I met you was the very
beginning of my career I had just
started as a writer on Star not live and
you were the guest host yeah this I
remember like it was yesterday because I
was on an airplane flying from LA to
Kentucky was to Kentucky Derby and I'm
reading the paper and said Wayne Gretzky
to host Saturday Night Live and I just
pulled down the paper like this and
looked at my wife and said no she said
yeah I called Lorne Michaels back and
said this is gonna be the greatest week
your life and as it turned out I had a
great time
so wait but so she said yes for you you
hadn't agreed to it that's that's a
scary way to fight you would said no and
then you read about in the paper that
you're gonna do it well you know
everybody comes to LA especially people
want to get in the entertainment
business but athletes come here and they
want to be actors sometimes but I never
wanted to act and you know I wanted to
be a hockey player yeah so I thought
gosh hosting Saturday Night Live now I
grew up watching Saturday night like
everyone else I thought my goodness
that's a lot of hard work Mike Myers is
Canadian and Phil Hartman's from my home
town and as it turned out I'm glad I did
it they were terrific every one of my
and it was was a very funny show and I
remembered it was one of the first times
they threw me into a sketch in the
background was I think was a Rocko hula
yeah Lauren called me in the office and
said you got to get this over the hump
you got to do a little bit of acting
because I really was on all these
different talk shows like that
anal-retentive and then Wayne's World
yeah and I remember us back in the hotel
room and my daughter at the time was
three months old and I was trying to
learn this song it was like Waikiki
hockey and I'm completely tone-deaf yeah
and I was singing to my daughter at that
time was three months old and I probably
ruined her yeah there was yeah and I
ended up singing and they threw I
remember that they said they threw me in
and I was so proud this is I was so
green that I told everyone I'm in a
sketch I think they thought that I had
speaking lines it just turned out that
I'm a minor figure in the background
playing the drum I think we have the
clip I think I'm in the background
I think you'll get your money
[Applause]
[Music]
halation the funny part of the scene was
they had this like little piece of meat
and I was supposed to sort of hit it and
I hit it right into a garbage can and I
think everybody's shocked that I put it
in the garbage can was just completely
by accident right but it was a fan
everyone thought like he's him he he can
fire me at will I remember when you were
traded from Edmonton Oilers Oilers to
the Kings it was a phenomenon that you
don't I don't I can't think of anything
comparable in sports people in Canada
lost their minds and there was just an
incredible upward that must have been a
difficult time yeah it was really
difficult because especially being 28
years old you you don't really
understand the business side of sports
and I was just a young kid was playing
hockey and loving it and one of the
greatest teams ever and over the course
of two or three months after winning our
fourth championship it sort of came to
me that I was going to be traded and it
came down to two or three teams and when
I was finally traded to LA and and came
here to play for the LA Kings you know
what's hard for especially people in
Edmonton because they weren't just fans
they were they were friends of mine yes
a lot of the people that go to all the
games I knew from all the years of being
in Emerson so it was difficult for
everyone but you look back at it now and
everything happens for a reason and we
love it here in LA and you know the NHL
is thriving and everyone seems to be
doing okay yeah it was just it was
treated I remembered that people said
we're losing Canada said we're losing a
national treasure national treasures
leaving Canada and people they said the
same thing about Bieber
[Laughter]
[Applause]